[Applause]
noon in Tehran and the country's Supreme
Leader delivering the sermon at Friday
prayers for the first time in eight
years in the complex and opaque politics
of Iran it's moments like this which
provide the clues on the country's
strength its direction the confidence of
its leadership and at an acutely tricky
moment for the Islamic Republic with the
assassination of a key figure and the
downing of a passenger plane the
appearance alone was an attempted
display of national unity with the
country's subservient president watching
the ayatollahs rhetoric was familiar
that car yi yi these American clowns who
with lies and utter evil say they stand
by the Iranian people they should see
who the Iranian people are he referenced
the European signatories to the
fractured nuclear deal the evil
governments of France Germany and the UK
are lackeys to America he said this is
something we've come to expect none of
it surprises us but what we do know is
that the supreme leader because it
continues to reject diplomatic off-ramps
to deescalate tensions in the Middle
East today is facing his worst economic
crisis in history deep domestic unrest
as the investigation into the plane
crash last week continues he echoed the
Iranian government's regret I want to
say that to the same extent that we are
saddened and felt grief in our hearts by
this plane crash our enemy was overjoyed
to the same extent he was preaching
literally to the converted here and
outside his loyalists but no doubt many
too who felt compelled to be seen here
how many really believed the mantra
death to America
watch here as one person walks around a
u.s. flag on the ground to be walked
over as large as the crowds for the
Ayatollah this Friday they have over the
past few days been protests a reaction
to the accidental downing of the
Ukrainian plane and this movement has
followed months of protests against the
Iranian leadership itself perhaps more
than any other country it is Israel
which feels genuinely threatened by Iran
and so they watch it
very closely indeed and it is the
assessment here that the Iranian
leadership is going through a
particularly challenging period the
pressure of sanctions is really hurting
its influence regionally is under strain
and domestically those protests are
getting louder and louder few were
predicting the collapse of the Iranian
leadership but what's not clear is
whether the pressure it's under and the
strains and power struggle within will
prompt more aggression or pull Iran back
to the negotiations mark stone Sky News
in Jerusalem